ladies and gentlemen we have made it to
the end of witcher is the end this is
the end this is the end of the witcher
valley season two done with the show
we're never coming back so enjoy it even
no matter how much you end up enjoying
this episode we're never coming back
good riddance goodbye to your witcher
all right well hit that like button if
you're excited for us to never return
subscribe and click that notification
bell so you don't get notified when we
don't cover the spin-off series nor
season three of the witcher also our
full-length watch-alongs where you sync
up with the time code something people
do not seem to apparently listen to when
i say that are over at our patreon page
yes come over there join our patreon
check out all the shows we have to offer
or at the same tier you get the option
for many shows that have reaction
highlights and watch alongs where you
sync up with the time code included if
you ask for a refund after not realizing
that i said do you sync up with the time
code
then that is on youtube that's on you
we'll still give this because for some
reason you're just not listening
we had some messages i had to handle
today and anyway guys listen the boys
have prepper you guys rock i'm excited
for you guys not to edit our reactions
for season three of the witcher because
we're done with this show entirely hate
all anyway guys can't wait for season
three excited for when that comes out
but let's finish off season two first
[Music]
this is a dream it's gonna be a
nightmare if you don't rub that sleep
from your eyes and get moving
the knighting ceremony started 20
minutes ago and your grandmother has
your dance card full
you know what's up
what are you doing
it's really here
it's all just a terrible dream
nice
is this the banquet from the first
episode probably
it's gonna come full circle
[Music]
take the dagger with you
[Music]
you're so mad at me
please don't be mad i'm sorry
i've chased you all the way back here
looking for your validation
look i know this means nothing to you
but i understand now how special she is
i don't know what vollis may wants from
siri but we have to protect him i
have to protect her i think it's pretty
clear what vol if mir wants with her i
mean he's got that elder blood
oh
man she's just taking them all out
that's the meow
siri
what's going on yo these witchers lack
serious awareness of their surroundings
some kind of security protocol anything
how did you escape
i screamed
and that didn't cause any damage
hit her
rip her face off
tell me what you want
ouch
wow
uh-oh
convergence
[Music]
symbolism
i don't know what it just seems so goofy
to me
look how awesome we are
get anyone who's left
merrick
she got married too
it's my spare can of whoop ass right
here all convinced well if mere to leave
siri's body
once the demon's out when she's back in
her corporeal form
or trapper would it work i don't know
but our best chances together listen
please trust me
can we trust you
i don't know i think that's going to try
to kill her
[Music]
thanks a lot jennifer it's all your
fault
he told me his target was nilfgaard i
never would have thought
this is not your doing
i need you to gather some horses
about from the extraction or separation
family would do it yes it would if you
had your magic which you don't if i had
my [ __ ] magic instead i'll have to
make do with whatever i find in a witch
laboratory chemistry i pull siri into
this mess and i'll do everything i can
to get her out of it she needs her best
friend fine gerald
give him the jasper
make him love me hang on what are you
gonna do what witches do best
make a potion
so her body is being controlled right
now but in her prison of her own mind
she thinks she's having a glorious time
at this banquet
and what the witch is doing is stabbing
people yep
slasher movie killing spree
as a member of the royal family is it
too much to expect that you exercise to
come off respect
it's not respectful then to rep your
highness
would you want me with a dance
she would have loved to
martin
marty
so much brighter i know than uh how it
was in that first episode yeah it's the
brightest most saturated day
there can be no mistakes when amber and
me arrives
just fragile the killer
put that on a t-shirt the baby gave them
hope
a reason to live rather than die
fighting now they're off to raise the
kingdoms of our enemies what are you
saying
i'm saying it what that's what's up
your plan you're welcome you should
rebirth that baby from the get-go
oh i would never do that you said it
yourself
fringella when amir arrives i need to
rave
so let me little bit of ecstasy
oh [ __ ] let's get it on elixir party
chug chug
[Music]
oh
i think they're gonna have to kill her
oh
she is a powerful one
what the [ __ ]
damn
siri
another one bites the dust
[Music]
oh that could go on all day yeah
full let's mirror knows how to use
serious power
oh no
oh there's two of them
[Music]
oh oh poor guy they ganged up on him he
put up such a good fight
come on you ask here get the sorcerer's
stone over there
owie
girl jennifer told me to give you this
it's it's balance and heat and oh you
can't hear me
oh no
never get to me
siri
you can fight this
stay
strong siri
no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what is she doing she's scourging all
the babies there are many elves left in
redania
are you sure there'll be no moving
forward without retribution are they
murdering all the babies yeah it's like
a passover of elven vengeance
this show hates babies baby hates them
well the elves just got a whole lot more
interesting
and one fell swoop
jesus christ
oh seriously
oh [ __ ]
this looks like the cup of a carpenter
more
[Music]
[Music]
it's from the jurassic park portal
gross
wow oh [ __ ]
balls nice
oh there's a roller coaster of some very
pulpy gore in this episode
you kill her
you kill siri
oh my god she can repair the dress too
our hate
is the pain she needs to grow stronger
let's not give her what she wants
let's look at the positives here
there's a lot going for us right now
come on
i've missed you so much
did you
i don't think you really knew them
yeah you know in a distant sort of way
if you can hear me
if you can hear us come home
stay with us
i'm not going anywhere
i'm not going anywhere
oh what a cool shot she needs a vessel
to exist within this sphere
sir he can't escape unless oh no
jennifer
i can be the vessel no
for her
[Music]
it's a hell of a transition shot man
what's gonna happen to yf
if you can pull monsters through the
monolith
you can send one back again
wicked
she's leaving
why
uh
nas school are coming
the army of darkness is coming
join us
your place is among us you are ours
time to scream
huh this wasn't too bad for jennifer
yeah
all things
the wild hunt
yes you can play video game if you want
to learn more
and also check out the shadow of the
wolf on netflix
no way
oh she back
now set this place on fire
princess cerella created far less
trouble for us when she was dead put a
bounty on the girl
and anyone who protects her
good idea damn it the elves are up in
arms of the death of their baby
nilfgaard is stoking the ranger to
foster another war in the north will no
doubt take the bait we will be focused
on getting the girl
wow
i haven't met you down again was it
worth it instead of seeing what they
really were and it led to a mass grave
we dug ourselves
i don't want revenge i want justice
now you're talking my name is history
i'm a mage i have some information i
think could help you princess cirilla of
sintra she's one of you
the one that he prophesized
he's saying she could save us
oh at least someone wants her for
something nice yeah
not a [ __ ] hell i know i've hurt you
yet i can't help but wish you could
begin again use your knowledge of magic
to train the girl you're the only person
who's helped to control her powers as if
i'd trust anyone else with her hmm
how did you convince them to fight by
killing their home
we lay the blame on medina
just pick that up
desperate times desperate measures
desperate
indeed that's how i felt when i realized
i could no longer count on you i'm the
one who ordered the death of that elven
baby
it was the best path to helping me
find my daughter
oh no
[Music]
oh
oh
damn cool
all this time we just thought it was
some [ __ ] [ __ ]
turns out
we've met him before i think there's a
post credit scene
good
just freeing my ears
i think it's the trailer for the
spin-off series oh i'm so excited what's
it
that's about when this
oh
yo yo
[Laughter]
get that dramatic cover
oh
[Music]
we're going back to the blood origin are
we going back to the times of the elders
i'm going to tell you right up front
right now
all the work that goes into editing down
these reaction highlights and just
putting the whole video together that
song's not going to be in there
with who copyright popular
seconds of a trailer i don't know
it looks cool i thought the episode was
awesome i thought the episode itself was
awesome yeah quite a thrill yeah quite a
thrill yeah it was cool that was great
all righty
all righty that was a good one man that
was exciting i like that more than the
last season finale in a lot of ways
actually
because uh you know it's like i like a
big battlefield fight but i thought like
having it all intertwined
into you know like something i felt like
a real personal conflict for all of our
characters as opposed to them all being
separated like obviously the most
interesting stuff is all the stuff
that's happened to kare morin uh with
you know like vesamir being not super
conflicted he seems like i know the
reason why killing this [ __ ] is because
i'm [ __ ] careful yeah
i seem to go along with geralt pretty
easy
um but yeah like the witchers dying uh i
wish i got to know them a little bit
better so i could kind of care it was
awesome when they first started getting
stabbed i was like i think those are the
witchers
you yeah those are the ones that are
always in the background that we never
spend enough time with you just flush
out the what remaining nine of them or
whatever yeah so i wish we got to know
them a little bit better but i'm also
okay because they've done such a good
job of fleshing out the other characters
so that was the most enticing stuff but
you know even some complaints that we
had about the last episode like one
thing i was you know one thing that i
thought we were
um really echoing amongst each other was
that we were hoping that a lot of that
would pay off in this episode i thought
it did there's a lot that was set up
here that had like everything was so
high stakes in this one and just amped
up to 11 like they really put the pedal
to the metal on this one it was so
high octane on like every story line
even the elf storyline
escalated but my main takeaway is that
mouse sack is always just gonna be
brought back as some alternate evil
version of himself that poor guy he's
such a sweetheart that mouse sack and
every time he comes back now
just a [ __ ] up version of mouse it's
gonna feel worse and worse and longer
and longer ago that we actually saw just
an unperverted version of him that was
authentic yeah yeah
he's gonna get consistent work playing
messed up versions yeah
but yeah no it was cool dude it was cool
you know i i don't the the motive of vol
with mayor
wanting to get back home seems a little
bit muddy but we're not supposed to
understand fully the context of it all
or does it stay from another sphere does
that mean like another essentially their
their language of another dimension is
that what you're getting at another
realm or something that's that's how
i've been taking it anyway yeah
but it's not the same earth i don't
think so i yeah that's where i get to be
like it's planetary the way they
no yeah the way they describe it it
makes me feel like okay yeah they must
just be like adjacent to dimensional
realms or something and yeah like
this doesn't look like
like some kind of overlay where it's
like oh we're where we were in karamorin
but this is just this sphere's version
like yeah i thought it was just like a
totally different place in time
yeah yeah i thought uh the actress would
play siri did such a cyrilla no wait
siri both yeah zero all of the above
cersei is the authorship yeah the
actress who plays siri is did such a
great job here you know like i i get
often distracted when
actors are forced to play like possessed
versions because they usually
all play it kind of they play it evil
yeah and i thought you just kept
noticing you're you're doing a pretty
good job this is like a believable
version where you're playing a character
still you're not just playing evil note
and the the conflict at hand i thought
was really interesting because geralt is
kind of outnumbered by motives around
him like no one really wants to save her
uh it's like this it seems even i'm
sitting there at a certain point in the
show when like these witches are having
basilisks bite their faces and heads off
it was just killers
but at a certain point you got to look
at the greater good my friend yeah
because i found myself getting in that
debate as well oh [ __ ] maybe you just
gotta like off this girl because this is
not doing an old card plan at all and i
think there's a lot of people who are
gonna die because of it i like chaos i
like the i like uh you know i don't mean
that as a pun i do like chaos i like the
crumble
of of stuff and i think it like to have
it you know come to a place of such
personal spots like this takes place at
care more in the this episode where this
is like where witchers are created this
is where geralt's home is that's where
he's supposed to go for refuge and rest
yeah and we got anything but this one
yeah this is
just another [ __ ] never come back
it's off rebuild i mean the way i
thought yeah we got to comment on it
with jennifer thought she got her powers
it's a little silly it's a little clean
and convenient it happens so rapidly you
know possess transport oh oh hey she
just want to go back
i thought like oh damn you kill her off
or or is it going to be like she gets
the magic back on a minute or yeah or
she becomes you know the full form of
volithmere or you know in getting back
to and delivering her to her home realm
maybe that's the extent of the magic and
then she comes back and doesn't have it
or something like that so yeah i mean it
is a little bit clean and that's
exemplary of something that you know i
feel like could have been maybe smoothed
over in
you know like this season has felt a
little more show-like a little bit more
sort of plot-oriented and i feel like
some of those earlier tones from the
first season of
just the more poetic exploration of the
story and the more sort of wilting
uh pace and alignment of the different
timelines like i think maybe that could
have smoothed things over with yen but
you know as far as the priorities of the
episode go you know like it wasn't a
major gripe but it was something that
felt kind of convenient given like the
second they arrive
as already the embers are dissipating
out and the wild hunt is coming and
we're sort of on to the next thing yeah
i think the season finale of the first
one ended um
i like that as you put at the poetic
town more of season one like once you
know geralt and siri
when they arrive together and they
embrace each other like that's such a
great moment or when
uh jennifer unleashes her chaos magic
like the way that's all realized i love
the mood of that more whereas there are
things in this season and even it really
actually showed a lot in this episode
especially yaskir like the way they
handled the comedy with him felt
like he was this sort of breath of fresh
air i felt in the light i like him a lot
don't go wrong i still love you always
happy yeah i'm always happy when he's
around but the way they do handle his
comedy now i feel like it it does feel a
little bit more
like television
comedy or something
writing yeah you've got to get the
mcguffin in there they're punching this
script up yeah yeah
we got him in here people love to ask
you whereas i always kind of liked this
show when i was a little bit more lost
because of the novel language that this
strikes you know yeah and the sense of
overall space i mean there's something
the season two is definitely crunched
down is like the sense of
where everything is
very far away whereas now everything
feels very close together
that's true it weirdly is even though
they kind of went a little bit to other
more places it felt smaller yeah it took
like way less time to get to any of them
and and it's like i think it's like you
can do those things maybe in the same
episode but i think just decoupling from
that timeline uh you know variance of
the first season does kind of hamper
that because then it feels like you know
every consecutive scene is kind of
happening in a similar linear time well
it's like a game map yeah yeah it is hey
yeah it's a good point it's like when
you play those you know open world games
you're like [ __ ] this taking forever to
get there yeah nice forevers it would
take in real life you know you can't
turn on fast forward watching yeah
upgrade to transporting yourself places
yeah so yeah i thought that was cool and
then the way it ends off with jennifer
and geralt going to watch over
the number one target in the world right
now like this ended with everyone just
going who need to capture her we need
her she's the king to marry her
to everybody to get her back she's my
daughter we need to she's she's this is
the key to restoring
the elven glory yeah
to bringing monsters through and
reigning on everything she's everything
this is her show more than it is
anyone's show at this point it's her
show this is all like every plot line
centers around her so i like seeing
where it's where it's coming together
ultimately
um
and i don't really have a complaint
about any of this i thought like the
action was exciting i thought that yeah
the basketball is coming through was
really cool the effects were great the
effects are awesome
both the cg and the practicals i mean
some of those gore gags and things and i
mean they really leaned into especially
like in the final scene where all the
monsters are coming through and there's
the wind in the portal but even two when
the wild hunt shows up i was getting
some like
wraiths
the wraiths yeah the nazgul uh i was
getting certain like if army of darkness
was more intent on being actually badass
kind of vibes like those sort of pulpy
horror-y uh you know medieval vibes yeah
that was funchy like that yeah it's got
that kind of like
you know crazy whooshing uh angles and
stuff and you know just the plates of
bones and everything it got me excited
for season three like it yeah it didn't
it did for as much as the show like i
think evidently feels a bit different
now
and they too i mean it was nice at first
i thought i was gonna complain about the
way they dealt with dealt with the
mirror because i was like oh he's
building this guy up all season long man
he's white flames everyone's salvation
but he's also kind of sinister who's it
going to be and then by the end i was
like oh yeah i've been sitting here
being like is he ever going to show up
and i thought that was a was a pretty
appropriate punch too you know i
definitely did not see that coming that
reveal certainly raises some [ __ ]
questions yeah it does
oh why is it where have you been this
whole where has duty been
they must have told some lie to siri
about why they left yeah did uh did uh
you know siri's grandma she hadn't have
anything to do with that
probably just tell them to lie
um but yeah knowing their bloodline and
such but then you have uh you know i
like what they ended up with fragility
here where they think they've done the
ultimate service
i like that they're caught on a lie
right away and i thought that
strengthened the the uh deathless mother
the volath mirror story two
because it does come back to bite
frangilla like it is a deceit to
everybody yes and that pays off in a
long-term way
whereas some of the deathless mother
stuff felt like it could have been a
little more proportioned i thought that
was a really nice uh tie up for for her
in that yeah cause she never realizes
the truth about that situation and then
of course you got the elves here uh
where wow that was mean that was really
mean
but yeah [ __ ] humans they're all
horrible we are a bad bunch we are
horrible we don't i feel like yeah we're
american we're the worst and i feel like
that endures through so much fantasy
novel reasons like humans and elves man
we were just always treating them like
second class shitty people where like
elves have like so many wonderful
abilities and things you would i i'm
often kind of amusedly baffled by how
much hate elves get in these things
well
because they represent
purity in a lot of ways and
we're the uh destruction of all that
we are the
body we are sin
yeah yeah
that's who we are man we are we are
absolutely it's true because uh man that
sucks it's like every every fantasy
thing is like
men are evil but they're also our
saviors
and those ones are worth lifting up
there's some cliffhangers that were cool
you know uh freaking baldy with the
black girl owls my dude awesome he's
gonna stay bald next season he's making
sure he's both sustaining a bald
old guy and then uh some people know me
around virginia
my dome
the fire guy and uh messed up facebook
that was such a weird un
like
to talk about just throwing something
into your mail mainly to just set
yourself up for another season
i was like the one that was just here to
set something up i thought you could
have saved that for the season three
premiere
yeah yeah like i like i like rants and i
like you know her and i'm all for like
yeah let's get weird like messed up you
know more b-movie characters in here but
also it was like here's one scene
and that's it that's the only
involvement they have this whole episode
i like that this all maintained a snowy
landscape throughout like the first
episode took place at night with it's
like a good visual bookend where the
first episode took place on a snowy
night
with its you know
very blue lighting that this has when
it's nighttime and then
uh
this one ends on that note with our main
characters there too you know except now
it's not uh not them having to come
together yeah they're already together
and i just gotta get some questions
answered no they're family they're a
family and they got some
things to work through
yeah they got counseling to do yeah but
not a care morning
i gotta get the [ __ ] out the hell out of
there
and it was nice to spend the whole
season kind of with caremoren
i thought that one of all the places
we've been
i don't know of all the places we've
been we've been to some places where
we've been like this place seems like it
would have been more significant than
people in the comments were like oh yeah
that place is way more significant in
the book so you know have kermore
actually be that was kind of nice
you know
i thought
vesimir
[Music]
was a little under
reused
he does have kind of one
conflict to keep going back on
for a lot of it
i thought he could have been
they could have showed some of his
cooler sides to for lack of a better
word they because i'm taking care of
business yeah because he's just kind of
usually like
sad or [ __ ] girls go on the show he's
tortured yeah yeah and he's always he is
it seems like most of his conflicts are
vessemer you're blinded by fear and rage
stop it
come back around i am geralt i'm the
calmest dude here
and i can whoop your ass
yeah you taught me well i don't even
need to look at you when i'm fighting
yeah
yeah
yeah it would have been and i mean you
know i i i really liked him as a
character but i do i do agree with you
there i feel like we could like the
performer more than like the writing of
it yeah i felt like we could have really
seen through that character's actions
like oh yeah this guy is the father of
the witchers all essentially the
remaining witchers where you know he
feels more like an uncle yeah it's like
if they were gonna go the path where he
is like uh his his days are long behind
him and he's lost hope and he just cares
about staying i thought they could like
lean more into that then like like pick
a lane and just really commit to that
where i didn't get the full effect of
either it kept ending on him just being
like
kind of just keep [ __ ] up
i'm just gonna say it all the time
me and my ever dwindling number of
witchers which what are they now down to
like four i know it's more great to it
than that that i'm
what i'm verbally communicating right
now so i know i'm not giving enough
credit it i'm just giving a general
consensus here about how i felt it not
best fear
overall like the performer a lot yeah uh
but i could have used yeah something
that gives a little bit more of that
like badass edge to him especially with
the excitement of watching him come in
here
with you know
netflix and you guys watching with the
wolf
yeah watch this movie where he's a total
man yeah or he's the lead character yeah
he's the one who trains gerald yeah yeah
and well yeah i think if they had had
more moments for him to actually you
know really get in geralt's head and
have geralt wondering like oh am i in
the wrong i feel like most of the time
geralt's pretty much like no i know it's
the right thing man yeah gary let's call
him yeah where if he had maybe had a bit
more sway or influence or more
ideological you know uh back and forth
with carol yeah it could have been cool
no i completely agree it was definitely
missing for me and this happened this uh
season overall
but you know some cool [ __ ] some cool
monsters some cool action some cool
effects
i think i still like season one more
um to be
like there's there's things about this
that are sharper and more punchy
and it's
this one is easier to be entertained by
because of the rhythm
the pace they simplify a lot more of
their dialogue they're aware of audience
feedback
they're aware of like okay i just send
to them book readers yeah yeah
well now i'm just like reading the
comments i wonder what season three will
be like maybe they'll come to a middle
ground because this season people have
been like they're not in the books at
all anymore like full of mirrors a
totally made up thing for this yeah
because i went on rotten tomatoes um
recently
and i was surprised that i i wasn't made
privy to this uh i went right to because
because i was complaining about because
we had our complaints about the
penultimate episode and i wanted so i
went out to raw tomatoes to be like what
are people saying about this
and then i saw that the the critic score
is higher for this show than season one
is like significantly
but damn the audience score is
significantly
lower
and
it was just kind of on par with the
original season's critic score isn't
like in the 60s or something i think
uh what the show no the audience yeah uh
audience receiving it's pretty low yeah
like not like terrible but it's low this
is definitely
drop yeah i think that's why you don't
really hear as much talk about this
season as you do the other one because
yeah and it's just funny to say some
[ __ ] and then you know just because
because
what um
enticed me to go check it out was
because i saw some comments of people
being like the way you guys talk about
it is just
some stuff we were saying was apparently
reflecting upon some people who actually
had read the books
of like i feel like they're not really
following we were saying like i feel
like they're not really following book
stuff anymore just based off the way the
show's being written yeah you can
even the way they do their action now
which felt feels less real and brutal
yeah a lot of times it's just so hyper
stylized or sometimes it's really cool
yeah and other times it's like just so
wacky yeah at times i am like let's go
back to that first episode with just
that choreography and punchy camera work
like because people have said you know
like this season especially they were
like in the books he doesn't really
fight that many monsters in general so
we're gonna have a like a monster of the
week to kind of add to that but i feel
like that creates a certain opportunity
for that kind of action whereas i feel
like part of
what made you know the action the first
season so gripping was that half of it
was just very tangible stuff you know
that was very personal and human based
oh yeah there's a lot of like cgi
enhancements in the fights yeah and
sometimes it's totally fine in my part
in my opinion and other times it's
not that great but yeah there are there
are things about
i would say contextually what i liked
about this finale more just from the i
the concept of
you know
boiling it down to
we're not hopping between like a big
battle and here's gerald's on the phone
and then we got like this is like pretty
contained everyone converges to some
extent it was all centered around a very
personal conflict and then it ends on a
note of a very personal ordeal where
everyone's afters here the world wants
siri and this all continues that
progression of tying into her importance
moving forward yeah and then i think the
actress who plays her is up for the task
of holding such an important character
yeah in this series they're all great
they're all fantastic
all right guys well here we are
we're done we did it we'll be back for
season three don't worry i know
some people don't pick up on my sarcasm
hopefully it won't take as many years
for it to come out now yeah
i got a spin-off show coming woo
michelle yo let's do this also i don't
really that's another show literally
nothing about that that was like
okay it looks like information
i feel like every one of these networks
needs to pump the brakes and go hey hey
maybe just pour all your resources into
the flagship show
before you go spinning things off
cinematic universe because yeah before
you go hey we're already running out of
book material let's keep that going
that's there you go
hey hopefully it's good hopefully it's
good hey guys let's end this with a pay
spencer running with you because this is
the final episode of witcher but this is
the first time you're pledging i think
is it i think we don't know maybe
sometimes people sign up with just their
first name and it gets confusing
well here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
look at what the name spencer means
right now do it spencer
spencer name meaning
steward oh
means stewart or administrator
john you got 25 seconds to work with
that all right well hey if there's
anything that's important in a in a
medieval inspired world it is the
stewards for they call so many shots
they keep aligned so many facts and
details about their realms and that's
what you do for us spencer it's all for
you
you are the steward the administrator of
the real rejects and that's a lot of
responsibility so uh we appreciate you
for putting that in much love buddy and
hey stay pledged
and i'm going to continue shouting you
out cause i didn't really times
your time's up you've messed up your
shout out
stay pledged because i'm going to give
you a better shout out
[Music]